are you ready for your pandemic vaccine
it's a comment we are already getting
word that by the end of today up to 3
million doses could be released to
governors
by the end of sunday maybe as many as 6
million doses and on and on we go
welcome everybody i'm neil cavito happy
saturday to you we've got a busy two
hours for you beginning first and
foremost with
really the biggest health news in the
land the united states
joins at least three other countries now
in getting a vaccine out to the public
and it's going to be a pretty
rapid fashion too in fact not only is
this the earliest approval of a vaccine
to deal with a pandemic
in human history it is also going to be
the most
quickly launched and into the public's
hands and
arms in the weeks and months ahead an
aggressive timetable
that pfizer says is imminently doable
and the administration says
is going to be done or else let's get
the read from lucas tomlinson at fda
headquarters in silver spring maryland
lucas what's the timeline on this
well neil as you mentioned is going to
be very aggressive in fact top
officials from the fda just concluded a
press conference here at the fda
where they said they were not under any
pressure from the white house to approve
this new vaccine
hastily they said it was the urgency of
the mission that guided them
president trump touting this
record-setting achievement from the
white house last night
today's achievement is a reminder of
america's unlimited potential
when we have the will and the courage to
pursue
ambitious goals as i've said from the
beginning a vaccine will vanquish the
virus
and return life back to normal the
pandemic may have begun in china
but we are ending it right here in
america
as you mentioned neil up to 6 million
doses of the vaccine will be distributed
across the country beginning this
weekend
ups is leading operations in the east
fedex in the west
the first shots could be given to people
as early as monday doctors and nurses as
well as the elderly are expected to be
top priorities
the head of hhs said in a tweet quote
vaccines will help bring this pandemic
to an end
which is all the more reason to double
down on the public health measures we
need to stay safe in the coming months
like social distancing and washing hands
operation warp speed officials want to
get nearly all americans vaccinated by
june which will require a massive effort
while the cdc has provided a guide to
whom should get the vaccine first
state governments will ultimately make
those decisions the head of pfazer said
getting emergency use approval so
quickly from the fda
was a team effort together with other
vaccine manufacturers
this collaboration is expected to
deliver
hundreds of millions of doses to
americans by the end of next year
it took over two decades to get a polio
vaccine approved neal
this new coronavirus vaccine in less
than a year neil quite an achievement
absolutely amazing um lucas thank you
very much my friend
lucas tomlinson following those
developments